I understand that you were on the road
to as a kid you traveled a lot yeah I
mean not quite like this though I mean
we definitely weren't a wealthy family
by any stretch but we weren't like
struggling for food but yes we did move
different places around England and yeah
you are an Australia too right yeah and
you meet good friends with them nicole
kidman yes right we should be part of
your life to you I saw a picture that
you posted on Instagram recently yeah
yeah great friends known each other for
gosh three decades now a lot to go
through a lot together and we were
celebrating her birthday Emmys and
things like that cause I hadn't seen her
for a while and we just happen to be in
the same town at the same time you're
tuned in Airways easy for us yeah now as
a mom do you find that it's important to
give your child more routine and
schedule and more more yeah I mean no
valence yeah alex is good I think
Adventure is great I mean it certainly
paid off for both my brother and I we've
been moving around and but yeah you
definitely crave the other when you've
got one thing hmm so I think balance is
value is important yeah and talking to
Jeanette the idea and the concept of
putting your life in a book right would
you ever consider doing the member know
anyone in
no I think I think I can understand how
wanting to encourage everyone really I
guess we do a little bit of that in a
different way just by being part of
other stories there's no way that your
experience is kind of form how you play
things and but that said yeah I don't
know
that there's lots of memoirs out there
but most employee of interesting
material and when the arm-wrestle is a
oh that was a great scene it's a pivotal
moment in our alliance yeah if you were
to our Russell woody would you win or
what he went on I think you've win but I
don't know maybe generosity you're right
he is a softy but we'd have a lot of fun
yeah I mean woody is just he's a good
time
guy you know him and his whole family
they were there the whole time and he
did so much he's so generous and yeah
and so raw as well what he did with this
character was Josey herb you know yeah